we're going to begin with this hurricane
lower which is now a category 2 storm
all poised to make landfall along the
gulf coast within the next 24 hours you
can see
the long lines of cars as thousands
evacuate the island city of galveston
texas
tens of thousands are also evacuating
low-lying areas of louisiana
now this storm could impact more than
450 miles of coastline
from texas to mississippi wcbs tv
chief weathercaster lonnie quinn has
been tracking this storm all morning
well actually for the last couple of
days
so lonnie what's the latest
well the latest as the storm has blown
up today today is going to be the day
for this storm to really take over
you'll probably have a landfall sometime
around maybe midnight or one o'clock in
the morning
but we officially now get this gail it's
a cat three
cat three is a major hurricane 115 miles
per hour moving to the northwest at 15
285 miles right now
from lake charles and louisiana take a
peek at how this is going to progress
we think it gets stronger still up to a
category 4 status maybe losing a little
bit of strength as it comes on shore
with a cat as a cat 3
with 120 miles per hour i'm telling you
listen to me on this i think it could
very well be a cat 4. i think it could
be a cat 4 making landfall
that pink line shows you where rita went
this is almost right on top of that
devastating
storm in 2005 there's going to be some
big storm surge with this but there's
also going to be some big rainfall
totals and not just along the shoreline
you go inland 80 miles you're still
dealing with a foot of rain the rivers
are going to be flowing backwards
because of that storm surge pushing it
inland
water has nowhere to go inland flooding
an issue as well guys let's go back to
you
all right wow lonnie thank you very much